when you go out to get a cup of coffee
or tea or whatever it is ask for 10% off
so like for the next 10 coffees that you
get each time ask for a 10% discount you
can't say you're doing an experiment you
can't say that Tim Ferris told you so
you just have to ask for 10% off it
doesn't matter if they say yes or not
and just sit there and wait for them to
respond did you do this Tim yeah what
would the conversion it makes you more
comfortable with discomfort and you also
realize the downside is so limited I
respect the macro amazingness no no no
what were the conversions oh the
conversions are surprisingly High like
70% seven of the 10 people at a
Starbucks or Pete's coffee or some
random Place were like okay sir yeah or
they're just like so stunned that
they're like wait this is Starbucks and
I'm like I know I would really
appreciate 10% off and like half the
time they're's like okay okay guy sure
yeah I don't want like I don't I don't
want to fight this fight right now so
okay fine 10% off yeah knock yourself
out I love
it